well not many small businesses will
still be open by the time we come out of
the other side of this pandemic
unfortunately
but we are happy to report that our
community across southern nevada
has really supported a european couple's
french bakery business
and their expansion efforts kirsten
joyce live in studio
with their story well there is a special
key to success if you open your second
business in the southeast part of town
during covid
and plan to expand with the third in the
southwest part of town
in the summer of 2017 carmen barber and
david vegazano opened la cafe du lac in
the quaint area of lake las vegas
we knew when we opened our first
location that there will be several
the second location look cafe duval
opened in the heart of green valley
ranch a few months into the pandemic
offering fabulous french cuisine black
forest ham and gruyere cheese galettes
paninis crepes been very successful but
it wasn't long until the pandemic
forced them to close we just didn't know
if that's going to be for one month
three months a year three years we were
just in the dark
they adapted quickly allocating a bigger
budget toward takeout i would never
imagine that the cost
of operating will be so high but that
smart move
saved their business and the day we
interviewed them they shared with us
their latest success
we literally are signing the lease today
we're very excited a third location
planned for southern highlands this fall
being open opening a second one to covet
and planning to open a third one during
covid
i think it just sticks to what we are
doing and what we really want to do
going forward carmen and david attribute
their success to something bigger than
offering great food and a great
atmosphere
it's the personal connection with the
people who support them remember
people's names
and acknowledge that they're returning
and i think that's what we do best
of course it helps to have great role
models carmen's mother-owned restaurants
in romania
where carmen worked during the summers
my mom was my biggest
inspiration and she was my mentor and
the one thing that she
taught me was to not be mediocre and at
an early age david was brought into the
restaurant business
his family owned cafes and restaurants
in the south of france
nowadays with two cafes here and
expansion plans in the works
it's all about divide and conquer david
is at the lake i'm here
he's really focused on making sure that
the kitchen is is ready to deliver
and i am here making sure that the
delivery is perfect
so it's a great it's a great partnership
really we really work well together
an incredible duo with big dreams and a
plan to see them through
sky's the limit we keep going hashtag
can't stop one stop
that's for sure well all the names of
the cafes reflect their locations the
cafe du lac the lake la cafe duval the
valley and the new location in southern
highlands
would be le cafe du suit south it
ideally would open in september or
october
and with such success don't be surprised
if they branch out encompassing a fourth
down the line
maybe centennial hills they said